yeah I saw you said that you weren't
playing like you weren't playing cards
you were just in your cell just focused
on
staying right mentally right now don't
get me wrong I ain't gonna just sit up
here and lie so I never played card okay
there were some days we got boring
there's a [ __ ] like and a [ __ ]
play a couple hands of domino a couple
hands of space but I never did like you
got guys who wake up every day and
that's their mission like they come out
they sell with a blanket they they cause
they probably know I'm talking about
from sun up to sun down they playing
dominoes man that's what they look
forward to every day yeah yeah man like
if you if you see that [ __ ] argue he
arguing about them Domino
you know it's people like that like that
use daytime Street you got your guys who
use their time strictly for working out
you wake up every time you see this
[ __ ] you working out he's doing
push-ups he's doing you got
[ __ ] who who who who like to go
to the law library and help [ __ ]
fight cases and get back you know I
spent more majority of my time like in
myself like I I spent majority of my
signs time to myself you know on the
feeds we got MP3 players so so I be in
my music I get in my zone I just I'm
staying focused on the Free World read
magazines and [ __ ] and how are you able
to update the music like like did you
ever store to buy stuff for every two
thirds in the face and a Bop Bureau of
Prison they uh update the music catalog
on a kiosk machine and uh you able to
download the new [ __ ] that didn't came
out oh wow yeah [ __ ] dope as [ __ ] what
was like uh your go-to like give me like
a few artists who you kind of discovered
while you were locked up that you like
you know well you know little baby off
the top yeah a little bit about the top
like I know I I peeped him out like I
thought I was locked up for probably
about 18 months yeah 14 months of [ __ ]
like that and I started hearing um I was
hearing I think it was I think it was uh
it's my dog yeah of course yeah that was
I mean well now him and Milos a lot of
money yeah a lot of [ __ ] serve a lot
of I like that [ __ ] hard I like them all
though too like you know what I'm saying
something like that I started listening
to this [ __ ]
um
uh it was a few of them that came out
while since I've been gone gone on you
know what I'm saying like a couple guy
that went out when I had went in and
[ __ ] but yeah you know like he was one
of the main ones out Ryan to what
working out too and [ __ ] all right now
[ __ ] to the little baby talking
and [ __ ]